do you have a license you better
government often demands licenses before
you're allowed to work people think this
is a good idea we license drivers we
license dogs people think it makes us
safer
but licensing also does something bad if
people want to work let them work 11
year old Madison root was told she could
not work because she didn't have a
license she wanted money for braces so
she tried selling mistletoe here she
isn't a tree picking it but when she
went to sell it at this outdoor market
police told her stop that's illegal
they told her she could beg but she
can't sell anything so her father sent
us this video I was amazed that people
cannot work hard but they can be just
lazy
I assume that's not exactly what the
cops meant but the fact is all over
America people want to work but can't
because it's so hard to get proper
licenses in the 1950s well only about
one in 20 Americans needed the
government's blessing to do their job
today that number is more than one in
three this new book bottleneck errs
reveals how licensing rules allow older
businesses to profit by keeping
newcomers out these are people who want
to erect barriers who want to put in
place bottlenecks because they want to
keep competitors out it's kind of like
what happens on a highway
if you close a lane the established
existing businesses are like these
motorcycles licenses don't slow them
down during my consumer reporter days I
assumed licenses protected us from scams
like these but licensing doesn't stop
that Georgia funeral director who was
pitching dead bodies out of the woods
behind his funeral establishment he was
licensed Bernie Madoff was licensed
teachers in public schools who have sex
with their students licensed licensing
doesn't stop that what licensing does do
is crush new entrepreneurs want to braid
people's hair this woman was told she
couldn't do it legally
unless
she spent thousands of hours to get a
cosmetology license she begged the
government just let me braid I was
making these phone calls to the Board of
Cosmetology saying I don't want to do
cosmetology all I want to do is braid
hair no not without our license said the
cosmetology board these are people who
have a clear conflict of interest of
course they do she wants to compete with
them cosmetologist got together and they
went to the legislature and they lobbied
for the creation of a license makes me
wonder how could I get rid of my
competition I'm annoyed by all these TV
channels yes I'm sure
so what you need to do John is that you
need to go to the government and ask for
special protection you need to claim
that there's some public interest some
way that the public is going to be
protected by limiting the number of
providers and that actually happened in
America when I started in TV most
viewers just had ABC CBS NBC and boring
public television people could have had
many more channels cable TV technology
was available but lobbyists from my
employer argued no that'll hurt poor
people they need broadcast TV they can't
afford cable
so the FCC limited cable TV for years
and that helped me make more money
certainly it does that's the effect of
licensing that is the people who were in
the industry have the ability to
artificially inflate prices and their
wages as a result and consumers are
worse off I was better off you are much
better off but now we realize everyone
else was worse off that's what the
bottleneck does it limits choices
thereby raising prices and enriching
older businesses there are so many
bottlenecks we'll show you a bunch in
the next episodes we'll also show you
how these problems can be better solved
by the free market market regulation
actually is enough for the vast majority
of occupations out there bottleneck errs
around America they make life worse for
you
you